jenny
i am it feels so bittersweet to be
talking to you right now because i am so
excited to talk to you but i am so sad
that we are talking to you this
soon so thank you for joining us today
oh thank you for having me i'm also sad
to be talking to you so soon but yes so
lovely to meet you erica thank you and
i think i speak for a lot of people when
i say that we are still so shook over
last night's tribal council so what were
you thinking after all of this craziness
happens and you find out it is your
torch that's getting snuffed that night
oh so upset so so upset so disappointed
in chanel for having missed her vote uh
especially when we told her she
shouldn't risk her vote before heading
on that summit she knew exactly what
that summit was going to be because when
i came back from it i told the entire
truth because i played it safe there was
no reason for me to lie i was really
disappointed in daniel
i came out during tribal that daniel was
sharing more information with high than
i realized i always knew daniel was
playing both sides i knew chanel and
daniel were playing both sides but to
the extent of information they were
sharing with the other side was a
surprise to me so that was hugely
disappointing hugely and then you know
worry for mike what's gonna happen to
mike now that his number one is gone and
everyone was aware that i was his number
one yeah
oh my gosh i mean there's a lot there
there's a lot to unpack there so let's
rewind a little bit because you you were
saying that you knew that daniel and
chanel were playing both sides so we see
on the show mike tells daniel about his
advantage did you agree with mike's
decision to share that information with
daniel
i was a little disappointed that mike
did that to be honest um but i know that
mike did trust daniel mike told him that
by the way when i was on my summit i
know like timing's a little bit off in
the edit but yeah i was away when mike
decided to share that information with
daniel and when i came back mike was
like i need to talk to you and when he
told me he shared it with daniel i said
okay well this is something i just have
to work with now mike clearly trust
daniel let me you know work with daniel
a little bit more and make sure that i
really have him on our side so i needed
to work to solidify my relationship with
daniel which was pretty good but i just
i still had a little bit of a lack of
trust for daniel um yeah
well going into that crazy tribal
council you know the the pre-tribal
scramble and you went on the summit so
you knew how this summit worked you knew
that mike had this advantage so going
into tribal council how many votes did
you think were actually at play and were
there different contingency plans
depending on how many votes there could
potentially be
there was there there was not honestly a
contingency plan and that probably was
my mess up but i also thought it would
have been silly of chanel to risk her
vote that because i'm like you we all
need votes here don't risk it as
precarious as all of our alliances are
sitting right now like keep your vote
so i knew there was a chance there could
only be four votes cast but i did also
think it would have been silly on
chanel's part to risk it um so yeah
you're right i i i didn't i'm saying
you're right as if you um
are do you think we have something i'm
just saying that for myself yeah maybe
there should have been a contingency
plan but we did feel strongly that we
had chanel and daniel in that moment and
the way that the votes played out the
fact that it was a tie showed that
chanel and daniel were still trying to
work with us because they could have
easily just thrown me away and
you know had everyone vote against me
and it would have been an easy vote out
but they chose to try to make it a split
vote and they got a little too crafty a
little too creative and ultimately it
didn't work to their advantage
yeah i feel like sometimes on survivor
and we saw it said on the show last
night people talk about go big or go
home and sometimes you don't always have
to go big
um
right exactly
so let's talk about now this crazy
tribal council there's the vote
it is deadlocked what were you thinking
when you saw it was a thai vote is that
what you were expecting
i wasn't expecting a thai vote so my
first thought when it was a thai vote
was okay chanel lost her vote she lied
to me
we also had no time to talk to chanel
before tribal council she came back from
that summit and then you know went and
gave her confessional and then we were
on our way to travel like five minutes
later so there was no time but um my
first thought when i came back to be a
tie was yeah chanel lost her vote and
then my second thought was
why is it a tie they should have just
voted me out so then i'm thinking chanel
and daniel are still trying to work with
us i don't know what logic they're using
to try to work with us and you know it
wasn't until i saw that secrets the not
not secret scene but
seeing of them to the side with hai and
lydia where chanel and daniel are trying
to get them to split the votes
i i understood at that point but in
tribal i'm like why was it a tie you
should have just you should have just
voted me straight out i didn't
understand that yeah
so
once you see it's a tie
and we get to this negotiation with hai
and daniel having to decide whether
they're going to vote for you lydia or
go for go to the rocks yeah i know that
we saw a little bit of your pitch to
high but can you tell us a bit more
about what your pitch was to hi and to
daniel
yeah i wish they had shown me fighting a
little bit more it does look a little
bit like i laid down but that's
definitely not true um before going into
tribal high mike and i had a
conversation about who to target and you
know we were never really working with
high but
ultimately we got high to throw out
lydia and daniel's names so you know at
tribal i'm leaning into that saying hi i
trusted you we can still work together
like don't worry about it i'm not mad
just let's get lydia out let's do this
we we can work together um so there was
a lot of that like and mike too mike was
in there saying like let's do this we we
can still go strong and you
you do see me say look you vote me out
every everyone's fractured like you guys
are all gonna dismantle after i'm gone
you keep me in we stay tight and we can
move forward together as a group
but then ultimately eventually um
i i had said to daniel look hi threw
your name out there so and i said that
just a few minutes before tribal council
trying to make sure to lock daniel's
vote in because i knew he was playing
both sides so i thought if i tell him
hai's throwing his name out there
perhaps i can feel the deal of daniel
voting with me um so it comes out during
tribal that daniel told high that i
shared this information with him so
at that point i realized okay my game is
sunk hai knows that
he knows that i'm not really working
with him and that's over and also you
know daniel said i'm not going to rock
so at that point that gives high an
opportunity to dig his heels in and say
i'm going to rocks
daniel what do you want to what are you
going to do about it so ultimately
daniel
yeah goes uh
yeah lets me go cuts me loose and yeah
goes with hi
i mean from the viewers standpoint it
seemed like
daniel was ambitious in trying a lot of
things at that tribal council and i feel
like you gave more insight into the
other things that he was trying so as we
see daniel doing all these things like
outing that chanel and mike are his
allies and um being so open to flipping
and then going to the other side with
hai and lydia what what were you
thinking as you're seeing all of these
antics
oh my god i'm thinking why did we ever
trust daniel we should have just
targeted daniel this whole time why were
we trying to keep this guy safe with his
bum shoulder you know we really mike and
i really worked hard to try to keep
daniel safe make him feel supported we
figured this guy is done with his
shoulder so he's got to lean on us and
trust us we also knew that daniel had a
better social connection personal bond
with me and mike so we knew that we had
him but i i was
as floored to hear
how much information daniel was sharing
with both sides because i always think
you know you play the middle that means
you collect information from both sides
does that mean you should share
information with both sides
no
and that is what daniel was doing um so
i was disappointed to see that he didn't
really pick a side he was still playing
the middle and seeing how tribal would
shake out um before he really drew that
line in the sand
i think that that's the crazy thing
about survivor because there's what
makes sense to you and you realize that
what makes sense to someone else might
totally not make sense to you and and
it's kind of figuring out how you need
to work with all these different people
doing different things absolutely
that's what i say like there's 17 other
variables out there i don't know what
these other players are going to be
doing i don't know what daniel's logic
was in doing that i don't know what
chanel's logic was in risking her vote
no idea um didn't make sense to me but i
can't control what they're thinking
well i feel like we've seen on the show
in the decision making that you've made
you are one to think things out and i
think you've always had a great approach
to your decision making on the show and
now
you know it's it's all said and done
hindsight is 20 20. what would you have
done differently
it's really hard to know what i would
have done differently i felt i had the
majority and that was proven by having a
thai vote in the end again chanel and
daniel could have totally threw me away
at that point when they knew they didn't
have the the votes to really make it
easy so
to
it's i've been thinking about this a lot
as as you do when you leave the game
what could i have done differently i
think
knowing what i do now i would have
pushed on lydia harder to try to get her
to align with me but she was acting very
um
[Music]
adverse to confrontation she she would
run away from me every time i tried to
talk to her so i think that knowing what
i do now i would have just pushed on
that harder but it's hard to say in the
moment right sometimes you push on
someone too hard and they crumble they
run off and and tell their alliance like
it could have blown up in my face so
hard to say what i would have done
different i i think that i did the best
that it did with the information that i
had and the crazy people i was with
that's all you can really ask of anybody
in that crazy game and you don't know
all of the variables and you just have
to do your best and now as we look
forward to the rest of the season
who are you rooting for to win survivor
42
oh man i mean mike was my number one
right so i was always rooting for him
i'm worried about him uh because he was
my number one and our tribe clearly
realizes that right uh the rest of my
tribe i do not i am not rooting for
anyone else on my tribe mike is
definitely the only one there but i was
asked this question earlier about other
tribes as well and i always had my eye
on omer for some reason
he seemed really smart when he would say
things i saw that he was good at puzzles
um he just he seems like a fun quirky
personality that i was hoping to you
know link up with later so he was
intriguing to me but
you know my my heart is to support mike
because mike was an awesome human being
and i think that he was underestimated
by my tribe in a lot of ways um so
hopefully he can sort of continue with
that underestimation and be able to get
through further
well jenny there's a lot of people on
twitter who told me they thought that
you were an awesome human being and i
think a lot of people are sad to see
that you went so soon
but
hey at least you went in a crazy
unprecedented epic way so
congratulations on your game
thank you so much for joining us today
and i wish you all of the best oh thank
you erica yeah i feel really good i went
out in a blaze and not just fading away
into the night so
yeah it felt really satisfying in that
regard but yeah i wish i'd been up there
longer i'm ready to go out a second time
if they want me but
i had i had such a wonderful time thank
you so much for today
thank you so much hopefully we see you
again
yeah